Hello world. It's a Raj and life
is pretty unpredictable, isn't it?
Probabilistic programming is a technique
that helps us build a AI that account
for real world uncertainty and we'll use
Uber's newly released tool pyro to help
us understand how it works.
Back when the glorious Soviet
Union was still around,
programmers wrote everything in
the assembly programming language.
They used three letter commands to
control which data got stored on which
register,
which mathematical operations the CPU
executed and which memory locations got
copied to where.
As you can imagine,
this was really tedious work but it did
allow programmers to create never before
possible algorithms.
After a while though they wanted more,
they didn't want to have to worry about
manually adding register values or
copying numbers from one place to another.
They wanted to focus on high level
ideas like functions and data flow.
So along came compiled languages like
c and scripted languages like python.
These higher level languages
let programmers do the
same task with much less
code.
Fast forward a couple of decades later
and deep learning coupled with big data
is now the cool kid on the block
processor speeds and storage capacity,
you have skyrocketed in capabilities.
So computers can process
data like never before,
which means programmers can
build tools like never before,
like one of the many possible
deep learning models.
The term model can be used to describe
a decision making tool or a way of
representing an idea using math.
We use models every day
to make our lives easier.
A map is a model of locations.
Sheet music is a model of sounds.
Even our brain is a model
of every decision we make.
Models can be deterministic.
That means that a given input will
always produce the same output.
There's no randomness involved like blink
one 82 but most models are going to be
probabilistic. That means they
take into account uncertainty,
which the real world is full of applying
the same input to this kind of model
twice could lead to two different outputs.
There are no guarantees.
Modeling.
This kind of uncertainty isn't easy.
So lots of machine learning models
that have been built thus far have been
deterministic,
but consider that pretty much all real
world data is incomplete or imperfect in
some way.
So having some kind of prior knowledge
of probabilities helps us make
predictions. This is what
Bayesean inference helps us do.
We make prior assumptions about how
the world is before making predictions.
We represent these assumptions as numbers
and can update our model based on our
observations.
When programmers started to implement
this kind of model programmatically,
they started to realize that, hey,
this is actually pretty complex to do.
It's not about keeping just a
few probabilities in your head.
You have to keep track of the
whole probability distribution.
So ideally we need the probability
distributions to be at the heart of the
program.
Since they are what is being manipulated.
All other elements should revolve
around these probabilities.
But with traditional
programming languages,
they're only used in obscure sub
routines at their most basic level.
Probabilistic programming languages
differ from deterministic ones.
By allowing language
primitives to be the castic.
The point of running the program is not
to find out what happens at the end.
It's to figure out the correct values
for the variables that define our
probability distributions.
What do we think the world is like?
What kind of distributions with which
kinds of parameters have the expressive
power to mimic the real world?
Most probabilistic languages are
built on top of existing languages,
but they're distinct enough in the way
they work that they can be viewed as a
language instead of a library,
one of the most popular ride
sharing apps in the world,
Uber has to match riders and drivers
to get them to where they need to go as
fast as possible.
This simple task requires
optimization at every single step,
optimal routing,
sensible pool combinations,
deciding optimal timings,
avoiding harassment lawsuits.
So in order to help solve these problems
and specifically model the uncertainty
of the real world,
they've developed a probabilistic
programming language called pyro that lets
engineers and build models that
use Bayesean deep learning.
It's written in Python and built on
top of the popular Pi Torch programming
library.
Pi Torch offers very fast tensor math
operations and automatic differentiation,
Aka gradient descent,
a popular optimization strategy,
both of which help make computation
faster and easier to create.
Pie Torch also offers dynamic graph
definitions instead of static graph
definitions. In tensorflow, for example,
you define a graph before you run it.
In Pie torch,
you define change and execute nodes
in the computation graph as you go at
runtime, and this approach of
feels more native to python.
The basic unit of pyro programs
is the stochastic function,
which helps us explicitly compute the
probability of the outputs given the
inputs.
For example,
if we want to draw a sample x from
this unit normal distribution,
then we could just do the following,
define a mean and unit variants.
Using variables from Pi Torch love you
fast heads or math and we can compute its
log probability according
to a normal distribution.
We can also return a sample using a
named stochastic sample using the pyro
sample.
Primitive naming allows pyros backend to
uniquely identify sample statements and
change their behavior at runtime.
Depending on how the enclosing the
Catholic function is being used.
If we had a bunch of data of daily mean
temperatures and cloud cover and what to
reason about how temperature interacts
with whether it was sunny or cloudy,
we can write out a simple stochastic
function that says use pyro dot sample to
define a binary random variable,
cloudy,
drawn from a distribution
with the given parameters.
Then convert the value to a string so
that a returns values of whether that are
easier to parse.
According to this model,
it's cloudy 30% of the time and Sonny's
70% of the time we defined parameters we
use to sample that temperature that
depend on the particular value of cloudy.
We sample in line three then we return
the two values of cloudy and temp at the
end,
whether specifies a joint probability
distribution over to named random
variables,
cloudy and temp.
So this model helps us reason about how
likely it is to be cloudy or sunny given
a temperature.
And because pyro is embedded in python,
stochasticity can effect the control flow.
For example,
we can construct recursive functions that
terminate the recursion randomly three
summary points.
Probabilistic programming is a technique
that models the uncertainty of the
natural world by embedding randomness
into the models that we built.
Basie and inference is a probabilistic
methodology that lets us use prior
knowledge to make predictions and Pyro
is a probabilistic language built using
python and Pi Torch that lets us build
Basie and deep learning models that are
scalable and efficient.
Last week's coding challenge winner is
Shannon Code who successfully built a
demo that uses a
blockchain and AI together.
He used open Ai's world of
bits environment to train
a reinforcement learning
agent and the AI stores the training
results on an immutable public blockchain.
Great first steps to getting
a fully autonomous training
agent for can start his
repo wizard of the week.
This week's coding challenge is to
use pyro to create a simple Basie and
regression model on a
Dataset of your choice.
Details are in the read me get humbling.
Go in the comment section
and the top two submissions.
Get a shout out for me next week, please
subscribe for more programming videos,
and for now I've got to go update
my priors, so thanks for watching.